you know our I'm not saying that you
know you have to take that position but
even and this was you know the late '90s
early 2000s they asked the chef they
said why don't you have a phone he
didn't have a phone in his house and
even when we studied in the ma that time
like I said late '90s early 2000s you
didn't have any phones you know I think
there was like one phone in the Marcas
and it was on a it was a maybe like a
satellite phone and it was connected to
a battery he said he said I don't need a
phone because it just distracts you from
you know it distract you from beneficial
knowledge if he said that about phones
you know a phone in the house what would
he say about smartphones you know how
much does this phone divert you as an
individual or me from things that will
benefit you in your worldly life your
business say for example you have a
business or you have a skill or you in
Academia how much does yourself distract
you from excelling even even more how
much does the phone distract you as it
relates to benefiting religiously maybe
before the phone you were memorizing
Quran studying knowledge but when you
now enter Instagram because of the way
it's designed you sit there an hours and
hours pass before you even realized I
think the most important thing because
the phone like social media like the
internet is a is a double-edged sword
there is benefit in it there is also a
lot of harm utilize it to benefit you in
your worldly Affairs and in your
Hereafter the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he laid for us a methodology he
said he said
s he said focus and strive for what is
beneficial for you and seek the aid of
Allah and do not believe